[موسيقى]
الحاضره والباديه والبحاره كل له طريقته
الخاصه في حساب الفصول والمواسم يختلفون
في الاليات ويتفقون في النتائج واهم
النجوم الحسابيه عند الباديه والحاضره
سهيل ليش لان ظهوره وخفائه مرتبط
بالتغيرات المناخيه والسلوكيات الزراعيه
واهم من نجوم الحسابيه عند البحاره الحيمر
لان ظهوره وخفائه ايضا مرتبط بالسلوكيات
المائيه بين قوسين البحر ولحيمر سمي بهذا
لانه نجم صغير احمر مثل النقطه ويسمى عند
العرب القدماء بالقلب فهو يقع وسط برج
العقرب فهو بمثابه القلب وعما كان يهوى
ويطلبوه واصبح لا يشكوه ولا يتعذبوا الى
كم اداري من تريد مدلتي وابذل جهد في
ضراها
وتغضب الشكر لله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام يغيب نجمه لحيمر مع مغيب
الشمس وهذا اماره وعلامه على بدايه هبوب
الرياح الشماليه المشوبه بالبروده كمقدمات
الحالات الشتويه القادمه تتخلق الحالات
المداريه والتي ربما تتحول الى عصير في
بحر العرب ولهذا يسميها البحاره بضربه
لحيمر كان الرياح تضرب السفن الخشبيه
فتغرقها ومده الخفاء اربعين يوما ومع
ظهوره كره ثانيه يدخل علينا النجمه الثاني
من النجوم المربعانيه اذا طلع القلب جاء
الشتاء كالكلب واصبح اهل البوادي
في كرب
[موسيقى]